Deadpool 2 is finally here and it left
fans with more than just a stitch in
their sides it also left them with a lot
of questions sure continuity and logic
aren't exactly important in the Deadpool
movie but there are still some questions
we'd love to have answered even if those
answers have absolutely no meaning
so grab your stack of x-force comic
books button up your 501s and get ready
for a bumpy ride because there's a high
wind advisory in effect for the rest of
this spoiler filled look at the biggest
unanswered questions in Deadpool - where
are the other x-men big house it's funny
that I only ever see two of you it's
almost like the studio couldn't afford
another x-man Ryan Reynolds and the rest
of the Deadpool gang have made a lot of
hay over the fact that the only x-men
who appear in the two deadpool movies
are colossus and negasonic teenage
warhead while it was just a wink and nod
one liner in the first film this time
around the rest of the team actually
makes a hilarious cameo deliberately
avoiding Deadpool because well wouldn't
you as funny as that was though we have
to ask where exactly are the rest of the
x-men
during the climactic final fight against
juggernaut one of the most dangerous
mutant menaces in the world is attacking
an orphanage filled with vulnerable
mutant children this is the entire
reason the x-men exist in the first
place and yet the only ones who bothered
to show up are you guests at colossus
and negasonic teenage warhead along with
her new girlfriend Yukio what else could
possibly be going on that's so important
Wolverine storm beast and the rest of
the team couldn't be bothered to make an
appearance of course they aren't quite
the same without Hugh Jackman
Quadra what happened to the rest of
x-force arguably the funniest part in
Deadpool 2 is the amazing sequence where
the newly-formed
x-force tries to parachute down to
attack the convoy carrying Russell only
for almost every single one of them to
be horribly and hilariously killed off
in graphic and preposterous ways saddest
of all of course is the death of
gregarious everyman Peter thanks to acid
vomit taking out one of his arms which
kind of sucks luckily during the end
credits scene
Deadpool uses cables time machine to go
back in time and change events so Peter
is saved which begs the question what
happened to the rest of x-force did
Deadpool bother to save the lives of the
rest of the team II assembled or did the
only save Peter we never find out those
comment about how nobody liked shatter
star suggests at least one member of the
team might not be back for Deadpool 3
what's the deal with cable in the comics
cable has a lot going on he's actually
from our time period sent to the future
to save him from the techno virus that
is slowly turning him into a robot he's
also the son of Cyclops and Jean Grey's
evil clone and usually uses his
inherited telepathic and telekinetic
abilities to keep the virus in check oh
and he comes back from the future to
protect the prophesied mutant Messiah
hope who he adopts as his daughter
future so like is any of that at all
happening in the movies is he still
Scott and Jean son his hope and adopted
mutant Messiah does he have the
Technovore or is that just a robot arm
does he have mutant powers at several
points in Deadpool to his weapons fly
across the room to him is that
telekinesis or some kind of
technological gadget in short we know
almost nothing about the movie version
of cable here's hoping we get to know a
lot more about him in the future no pun
intended is Vanessa actually deaf so is
Vanessa actually the avatar of death
bear with us on this one
in the first Deadpool film Wade Wilson
has a super healing factor that even
kept him from dying when he was stabbed
through the brain it's pretty powerful
but in Deadpool 2 his power levels seem
to be cranked up more than a few notches
fact he completely blows himself apart
in the opening sequence with his head
flying off in all his limbs going every
direction only to get pieced back
together in effect Deadpool is now
immortal something he mentioned several
times in the film claiming he just can't
die this is actually true in the comics
where Wade falls in love with death who
takes the form of a beautiful woman
death has a jealous ex though who you
might know
Pano's he curses Deadpool with
immortality so that Wade and death can
never be together only meeting
occasionally in brief flashes of the
afterlife when he is literally on
death's door just to be yanked back to
life no matter how hard he tries that
sounds a whole lot like the relationship
Wade and Vanessa have throughout
Deadpool - after she is killed in the
opening sequence sure he eventually
brings her back to life during the end
credits sequence but still we have to
wonder if Vanessa is actually deaf which
would explain why he can't die why he
sees her when he's close to dying and
even why he got cancer as soon as they
started a relationship will there be a
Deadpool 3 finally the big question on
everyone's mind will there even be a
Deadpool 3 with Deadpool to set to
become another box-office smash it's a
no-brainer that the folks at 20th
Century Fox would love to make another
one and fans are certainly clamoring for
it but Ryan Reynolds recently told
Entertainment Weekly that he's not so
sure why well for the best of reasons
he's not convinced it would be a good
story saying in order for Deadpool to
function properly within his own
universe you need to take everything
away from him I don't think you can keep
doing that I do see him as being part of
exports obviously I would love to see
him in a team-up sort of thing I just
think if you're going to do another
Deadpool solo film you've got to really
like get that budget down to nothing and
just swing for the fences and break all
kinds of weird barriers and do stuff
that no one else can do luckily there's
an x-force film currently in development
and the end of the film certainly seems
to set up a team spin-off so one way or
another there looks to be more Deadpool
in our future and hopefully more Peter -
that guy is the best as it turns out we
are looking for someone with diabetes
Peters your man thanks for watching
click the looper icon to subscribe to
our YouTube channel plus check out all
this cool stuff we know you'll love -
you
[Music]